I've been a journalist for more than
twenty three years at the Arkansas
democrat-gazette
the Pittsburgh tribune-review and most
recently the Denver Post when I started
at the Denver Post in 2003 it was among
the country's 10 largest newspapers with
an impressive subscriber base in nearly
300 journalists at the time I was in my
30s in the ambitious journalist that age
aspires to work for one of the big
national paper's like the New York Times
or The Wall Street Journal but I was
simply blown away by my first few weeks
at the Denver Post and I thought this is
gonna be my paper I can make a career
right here well seven years passed we
were sold to a hedge fund Alden global
capital within a few years some of you
know this story
within a few years by outs ordered by
past and present owners would reduce the
newsroom by nearly half and I understood
the rule of thumb used to be that 80% of
a newspapers revenue came from pricey
print ads and classifieds with emerging
giants like Google and Facebook and
Craigslist those advertising dollars
were evaporating the entire industry was
undergoing a massive shift from print to
digital Aldens orders were to be digital
first take advantage of blogs video and
social media they said that one day the
money we made online would make up for
the money we lost in print but that day
never came in 2013 we won a Pulitzer
Prize for covering the Aurora theater
shooting Alden ordered that more
journalists be cut again and again and
again and again we were forced to say
goodbye to talented hard-working
journalists we considered not just
friends but family those of us left
behind were stretched impossibly thin
covering multiple beats and writing
rushed articles inside a windowless
meeting room in March of 2018 we learned
that 30 more would have to go this paper
that once had 300 journalists would now
have 70 and it didn't make sense here
we'd won multiple Pulitzer Prizes we
shifted our focus from print to digital
we hit ambitious targets an email from
the brass talked up the post profit
margins which industry experts pegged at
nearly 20 percent so if our company was
so successful and so profitable why was
our newsroom getting so much smaller and
smaller I knew that what was happening
in Colorado was happening around the
country since 2000
for nearly 1,800 newsrooms have closed
you've heard of food deserts these are
news deserts they are communities often
entire counties with little to zero news
coverage whatsoever making matters worse
many papers have become ghost ships
pretending to sail with a newsroom but
really just wrapping ads around filler
copy more and more newsrooms are being
sold off to companies like Alden and in
that meeting their intentions couldn't
have been clearer harvest what she can
throw away what's left so working in
secret with a team of eight writers we
prepared a special Sunday perspective
section on the importance of local news
this the Denver rebellion launched like
a missile and went off like a hydrogen
bomb
[Applause]
clearly we weren't alone in our outrage
but as expected I was forced to resign
and a year later nothing's changed the
Denver Post is but a few lone
journalists doing their admirable best
in this husk of a once-great paper now
at least some of you are thinking to
yourself so what right so what let this
dying industry die and I kind of get
that for one thing the local news has
been in decline for so long that many of
you may not even remember what it's like
to have a great local paper maybe you've
seen spotlight or the paper movies that
romanticize what journalism used to be
well I'm not here to be romantic or
nostalgic I'm here to warn you that when
local news dies so does our democracy
and that should concern you
and that should concern you regardless
of whether you subscribe here's why a
democracy is a government of the people
people are the ultimate source of power
and authority a great vocal newsroom
acts like a mirror it's journalists see
the community and reflect it back that
information is empowering seeing knowing
understanding this is how good decisions
are made when you have a great local
paper you have journalists sitting in on
every city council meeting listening in
to State House and Senate hearings those
important but let's face it sometimes
devastatingly boring committee hearings
journalists discover the flaws and
ill-conceived measures and those bills
fail because the public was well
informed readers go to the polls and
they know the pros and cons behind every
ballot measure because journalists did
the heavy lifting for them even better
researchers have found that reading a
local paper can mobilize thirteen
percent of non voters to vote thirteen
percent
that's a number that can change the
outcome of many elections when you don't
have a great local paper voters are left
stranded at the polls confused trying to
make their best guess based on a
paragraph of legalese flawed measures
pass well conceived but highly technical
measures fail voters become more
partisan recently in Colorado our
governor's race had more candidates than
anyone can remember
in years past journalists would have
thoroughly vetted scrutinized
fact-checked profile debated every
contender and the local paper the Denver
Post did its best but in the place of
past levels of rigorous reporting and
research the public is increasingly left
to interpret dog and pony show stump
speeches and clever campaign ads for
themselves within them advertising
costing what it does electability comes
down to money so by the end of the
primaries the only candidates left
standing were the wealthiest and best
funded many experienced and praiseworthy
candidates
never got oxygen because when local news
declines even big ticket races become
pay to play is it any surprise that our
new governor was the candidate worth
more than three hundred million dollars
or that billionaire businessmen like
Donald Trump and Howard Schultz can
seize the political stage I don't think
this is what the founding fathers had in
mind when they talked about free and
fair elections
now this is exactly why we can't just
rely on the big national papers like the
journal and the times and the post those
are tremendous papers and we need them
now
my god more than ever before but there
is no world in which they could cover
every election in every county in the
country
no the newsroom best equipped to cover
your local election ought to be your
local newsroom if you're lucky and still
have one when Election Day is over a
great local paper is still there waiting
like a watchdog when they're being
watched politicians have less power
police do right by the public even
massive corporations are on their best
behavior this mechanism that for
generations has helped inform and guide
us no longer functions the way it used
to you know intimately what the poison
national discourse feels like what a
mockery of reasoned debate it has become
this is what happens when local
newsrooms shudder and communities across
the country
go unwatched and unseen until we
recognize that the decline of local news
has serious consequences for our society
this situation will not improve a
properly staffed local newsroom isn't
profitable and in this age of Google and
Facebook it's not going to be if
newspapers are vital to our democracy
then we should fund them like they're
vital to our democracy
[Applause]
we cannot stand by and let our watchdogs
be put down
we can't let more communities vanish
into darkness it is time to debate a
public funding option before the Fourth
Estate disappears and with it our grand
democratic experiment we need much more
than a rebellion it is time for a
revolution thank you
[Applause]